[Music]
realtalk Selena Gomez you and your best
friend Fran Shaw Raisa are the epitome
of relationship goals she loved you so
much she gave you a kidney some friends
out there don't even want to share
clothes watching her make such a huge
sacrifice for you gave us all the feels
we wish you and her the best health in
the future and we know that you will
stay best friends forever hope that this
inspires people you're going to know
that there is really good people in the
world
Selena isn't the only actor who almost
had to quit for health reasons it might
surprise you to know that even our
favorite celebrities face struggles with
illness here are 10 actors who almost
had to quit for health reasons Selena
Gomez Selena Gomez has been very
outspoken about her battles with lupus
depression and anxiety when her kidneys
began to fail she got the most amazing
gift ever her best friend and fellow
actors Franchot Raisa gave Selena one of
her kidneys she saved my life afterward
when Selena's white blood cell count
decreased due to lupus she had an
emotional breakdown Selena was admitted
to a psychiatric hospital so she could
recover the 13 reasons why producers
said she believes this is a battle she
will have to face for the rest of her
life but she's ok with that because she
knows she is choosing herself over
anything else
Sarah Hyland Sarah Hyland from the show
Modern Family has been through a lot of
health challenges in her 28 years of
life it was the worst and best year of
my life she has had 16 surgeries
including two kidney transplants after
her first kidney transplant from her
father failed she had to get another
kidney which was donated by her brother
Sarah battled with mental illness and
found it hard to talk about what she was
going through but her health is now
steadily improving
Jonah Hill Jonah Hill got very sick
while filming the wolf of wallstreet you
might think it was because he wasn't
eating healthy or not getting enough
rest but in reality it was because he
was ingesting too many vitamins at first
he felt super strong like he could lift
a car over his head from all of the
vitamin D but later his body couldn't
handle the vitamins and Jonah had to be
hospitalized Gina Rodriguez the Jane the
virgin star was only 26 years old when
she was diagnosed with Hashimoto's
disease this is an autoimmune condition
that impacts the thyroid glands it
causes fatigue joint pain wheat gained
in memory loss when you're an actress
who needs to memorize lines a foggy
memory can be a major problem you know I
would fight depression and I would fight
my body changing Gina shared that she
really transformed her condition by
eating healthy and exercising
she said that eating a well-balanced
diet and staying active helps her feel
energetic and happy
emma watson when emma watson was on set
filming Darren Aronofsky's movie Noah
she got pretty sick the film has a
pro-environment message because of this
Darren didn't want anyone drinking from
water bottles on set emma was exhausted
and delirious from working long hours
without thinking she reached for a mug
and drink water that had been sitting in
the trailer and growing bacteria for
three months she got so sick but the
director insisted that she keep on
filming Channing Tatum while filming the
movie Eagle Channing Tatum suffered a
very unfortunate injury he had to get
into this freezing cold Scottish River
the crew was supposed to keep him warm
by mixing boiling water with river water
and pouring it into his wetsuit but the
crew member forgot to mix in the river
water so Shannon had straight boiling
water poured over a very sensitive area
of his body he had to be hospitalized
luckily he recovered and everything is
fine now
ouch Lena Dunham Lena Dunham disclosed
that she has suffered from endometriosis
for over a decade
I've always grappled with my physical
health I've grappled with my mental
health endometriosis
is a very painful condition that can
cause fatigue pain and problems with
fertility the only way to treat this
condition is with medication for pain
and sometimes surgery her illness forced
her to cancel her nationwide Lenny IRL
tour eventually Lina had to have a
hysterectomy due to her condition she is
feeling so much better now and it's even
exploring alternative ways to have
children Missy Elliott Missy's friends
knew something was wrong when she
started losing weight and had terrible
headaches a few years back as it turns
out Missy was diagnosed with Graves
disease stress can really exacerbate
this illness graves can cause hand
tremors and eye bulging - since she
slowed down and got a medication she is
doing so much better
Kim Kardashian Kim has been pretty open
about her struggles with the psoriasis
this is an autoimmune condition that
causes raised scaly bumps on the skin
she asked the Twitterverse if anyone has
taken medication for psoriasis and which
ones everyone recommends Kim has been
battling this illness for a while this
condition was affecting her self-esteem
which made filming Keeping Up with the
Kardashians a little more challenging
Demi Lovato when Demi Lovato was 18
years old she was diagnosed with bipolar
disorder this is a mental illness that
causes a person to have an episode where
they're hyper energetic and manic one
day and totally pessimistic and
exhausted the next Denny uses exercise
and medication to control her illness
keeping her career afloat and balancing
her health issue is a challenge but Demi
is a fighter through and through your
middle almost doesn't have to define who
you are as a person
which one of these stars is your
favorite and did you know about their
health issues tell us in the comments
thanks for watching the things subscribe
to this channel to stay up to date with
our latest videos and be sure to hit
that thumbs up button see you next time
[Music]